is it difficult to be open about being a
Scientologist when it's become sort of
very I feel like it's very trendy right
now people really want to expose
Scientology for whatever it is and it's
like you know Leah Remini has the show
or just documentaries coming out every
other week or whatever it is is it
difficult for you to just be like this
is just part of my life yeah I don't
know it's interesting because because it
is this source of controversy that that
somehow became this thing and and the
more you talk about it or have unearthed
these people that have had problems the
more you know you can have something
create something that's controversial
and for me and I speak speak of that but
it's just my perspective and my own
outlook on it that you know it's it's a
personal thing it's something that works
for me and and I think it's it's that
simple a lot of people want to talk
about it or have opinions about it and
and you'll find that most of those
individuals from Isaac's perspective and
I and I speak to a lot of people about
that that they've never read or really
are not educated as to what Scientology
is they've never read anything that
hovers however it's written and and yeah
I mean it becomes it's this interesting
thing because you go it this is my my
religion my the philosophy that I study
that is essentially an applied religious
philosophy the other people who come on
to shows or do interviews or talk that
don't get really asked about being
Christian or Jewish or yeah distr and
and positive Scientology's newer so you
don't I mean it's almost like when you
at the birth of Christianity or
something now this is kind of a newer
one so there's more sure yeah and you
know it is I think that before you are a
Buddhist or Christian Scientologists
you are who you are and and I don't
think that you know maybe Lea who I've
known since I was a teenager had a
problem what I see by my I was sneaking
suspicion that it was probably an issue
with one or two people in the Church of
Scientology that or maybe it's broader
than that and then it just seems to have
festered I I do have to say though I you
know I I can't help but wonder what
somebody who's doing a series a whole
season about that subject that they're
not getting paid and there's a lot of
money behind it it's turned into such a
controversy to where you go out you make
a documentary about it so you know the
person who's doing that is making money
off so there could be other motives yeah
and so that's you know I again it's it's
not even necessarily that that's
something that I would care to discuss
to the extent because because it is
something where if somebody has a
question it's just somebody like the
only thing that you can really say is
yeah it works for me and you know if
you're curious about it go ahead go pick
up a book